if you can use this I want to show you
how you can make a spare key for your
vehicle check this out I'm Mike with
Tom's key company we've got one fob for
this 2015 Jeep Grand Cherokee we're
going to make a spare key come to
tomskey.com where you can place your
order to get a programmer spare key sent
to you today it's important for you to
know you've got to have at least one
working key fob for your vehicle in
order for Tom's key company to help you
make a spare for your vehicle watch how
easy this is okay to get started we've
got one working key for this 2015 Jeep
Grand Cherokee and have a spare key here
the original is an oem with a Jeep logo
spare is an aftermarket which works just
great
so during programming you're going to
have to have your key fobs far enough
away from the vehicle so the only one
key is detected
so to do that you get out of the vehicle
and go find and set these uh inside the
house the other side of the garage make
sure they're far enough away
[Music]
and try and start the engine
it doesn't want to start
it's giving us an error
it can't detect the keys we can bring
the keys in one at a time
now we know where to set the keys so
they're far enough away that we can
program the new one
and here's the programming device first
thing you need to do is use your phone
scan download the app
with the app installed let's start
programming
going to come into key pairing here
first you need to scan the QR code on
this device it'll help it as it pairs
with your VIN number
make sure you get the QR Code by the
serial number right there
okay it warns you you need the internet
connection got to have all the keys that
you plan to pair as well as your
original keys and repairing tools so
let's get going
to come in and select our vehicle 2015
Jeep Grand Cherokee and it asks if that
looks like my original key yep
that key does look the same
okay we need to download a file for Jeep
let's get that going
now while we're waiting I'll let you
know the app will get better over time
so some of the steps may be a little bit
different when you perform the
programming process for your vehicle
so follow the instructions on the app it
should walk you through step by step
nice and easy
okay our Jeep data is installed
all right we've got to plug our
programmer into the OBD Port that's down
near the gas and brake pedal
come down here you're gonna have to look
around to find the port
that it fits into and plug it in
now you'll see it light up it's a little
hard to see the light
[Music]
so I'm going to use this extension cable
you can pick one of those up to make
your life a little bit easier
all right I've got this guy plugged in
and let's go ahead and hit next see the
green light
[Music]
okay we're going to scan for the
Bluetooth
okay the phone pulls up I see the same
serial number there and it's 284 so
let's try and pair it
should get a pairing request yep
okay
we're connected we saw light turn blue
it's connected now it's scanning it's
checking to make sure it's got the
current firmware in this device you may
find that the light turns red and it has
to update that's okay perfectly normal
all right there it's detected the new
version so it's disconnected
light went green blue we should turn it
red okay now it's updating the firmware
okay
great successful
we got to get this thing paired again
it's trying there
we're reconnected okay
hit next
all right we're up to date so
we're back out
may need to start the app over at this
point depending on your vehicle and
depending on how the update
took place
okay this one we don't need to count
down turn on the ignition within 30
seconds
pushed it twice
saw the lights flash up it shows run
right here
[Music]
okay we're going to take the original
key in the vehicle start the vehicle
here's my original working key with the
tile key finder you can pick one of
those up as well
pairs to your smartphone so you never
lose your keys
let's start the engine
push the brake engine started
okay
put next
checking the vehicle status
communication going on here
now this device pairs with the VIN for
your vehicle so you can use it to make
multiple keys but you can't use it on
additional vehicles
turn off the ignition
okay ignition's turned off
turn on the ignition without depressing
the brake pedal okay
I'm gonna click it twice
everything light up
[Music]
all right give some important
information key pairing will not cause
existing keys to be erased up to eight
keys can be paired to the vehicle this
vehicle currently has two so somewhere
in the world prior car dealership or
prior owner somebody lost a key and we
only have one for the vehicle right now
so we're going to program one key by the
time we're done that should go from two
to three keys
there's a new one we're going to pair
okay I turn the ignition off
all right turn on the hazards okay
hazards are flashing communicating
it's going to take up to 10 minutes here
now I will say if it's a hot day you can
roll down your windows before you start
this process you don't want to be
getting in and out of the vehicle while
the programming's going on
while we wait a quick reminder keep
watching to see the magic of our key by
photo service
okay we're almost done there we go we've
reached 100 okay remove all smart
devices and paired keys from the vehicle
place the first key to be paired close
to the center console all right so I've
got to go get this key away from the
vehicle
okay notice it tells me where to set
this key
let's set the key right here that's
important because there's a sensor in
there that will sense this new key
okay communicating countdown
first key repeatedly press and release
unlock on the key within 30 seconds keep
the key on the center console
[Music]
okay key pairing complete I just heard
the doors locked
all right that wasn't too bad was it
okay
that should be it let's test this thing
out
I'm gonna unplug programmer
turn off my flashers
we've got this is the only key in the
vehicle the other one's far enough away
where it can't be sensed
look at that can you believe how easy
that was
why the dealership wants 400 for that I
don't know
okay let's make sure this original one
still starts the engine
great
okay let's make sure the buttons work
here's the existing one
lock unlock works and here's our new one
look at that
rear hatch here's our new key fob
here we go
okay now you want to make sure the
emergency keyblade in your new key is
cut be sure you add our optional Key by
photo key cutting service
after you complete checkout upload three
pictures of your Keyblade
from directly above so we can cut it so
that your new key fob arrives with the
keyblade cut already fitting your
vehicle
visit help.tomskey.com
to find helpful information you can also
reach our customer support via email
help tomskey.com or
within the instruction manual there's a
phone number you can call technical
support is open there Monday through
Friday Eastern business hours we'll help
solve the problem to get your spare key
fob made and working for your vehicle
and never fear if we can't solve the
problem we've got a full money back
guarantee just let us know ship
everything back and we'll refund all
your money it's that easy if you've lost
all your keys I'm sorry about that go
check out our all keys loss section
where we'll point you to a company that
can come to you and help you make a
spare
be sure you leave a comment to this
video please let other people know if
Tom's key company has helped you make a
spare key for your vehicle just how easy
it was
or if you got a rip-off price from the
car dealership
leave a comment let other people know
how much money you save with the help of
Tom's key company be sure you subscribe
and like the video so you can find your
way here again when it comes time for
you to program your key visit
tomskey.com and place your order today